access to Medical Care has always been
an issue for those in our community that
are most at risk now that care is coming
closer to them Brian
explains how a new clinic will help the
homeless and
serve populations receive Medical Care
without the need for transportation
[Music]
[Applause]
so it's a full service Primary Care
Clinic that we offer here providing
Quality Health Care to those who need it
the most that's the mission of this new
facility at the Las Vegas Rescue Mission
so we're trying to do our part to be
able to create Baseline care this is one
of the exam rooms here at the
neighborhood Clinic helping some of the
most vulnerable of our community the
benefit to something like this is it is
like I said it's just centrally located
and people don't need a huge triage
process to get in they can they can come
in and they can check in and it's right
here where the majority of the the
clientele that we deal with that are
experiencing chronic illness the clinic
has already seen 400 visits so far
before the clinic patients would have to
travel for primary medical care but now
the Care is coming closer to them
removing some of the barriers to health
care whether you have insurance you
don't have insurance you have the
ability to pay you can't we're open here
for everyone the clinic is already
collaborating with several organizations
looking to expand across the valley and
set an example for the future of medical
care for underserved populations across
the country reporting in downtown Las
Vegas Brian will 8 News Now
they plan to add 10 more neighborhood
clinics across the valley that by the
end of this year